what a deep cut
oh my god that's how he looks
that's full on galactus
wannabe galactus i love a good forward
guy
we're going under
so real even the mad titan believed it
oh this lucky guy juice wait
hid as inanimate daybreak of
what death the hell enemy debris we did
a video about that
how did you do that years
i love this episode yes so
good welcome back to new rockstars loki
episode 5
was a true journey into mystery not just
a nod to the original comic series that
loki and thor appeared in but a
delightful grab bag canonizing in the
mcu
things like throg the thanos copter
kang technically and one of the
insanest fan theories that we discussed
on this channel
all the way back in 2018 which means you
know what no more
apologies none mephisto's back on that
table
and wait a little bit
[Music]
this is inside marvel new rockstars loki
after show i'm eric voss my easter egg
breakdown of the episode is coming
tomorrow it's gonna be a doozy
but here with me to discuss this episode
is
empty dude this episode man i loved
every single part of it
it's so great it's especially of course
my man
gator loki taking the bite out of
president
straight up exactly i mean
it's this has to be i think if not my
favorite one of my favorite hours of
marvel content that i've ever seen
just so much is delivered to us it's so
epic in proportion the the production
design is
crazy the humor is all over the place
it's just littered with easter eggs
i mean there we joked last week that
like oh the
loca gator could be based on um you know
there's a reality where thor is a frog
and wouldn't you know what we see
in a canister in a great floorboard gag
oh my god so good i hope he's freed at
the end of this
like please free throg it's so sad to
see him in a jar
uh well there's a lot to talk about this
episode so loki's exile is confirmed to
be what's called the void which is kind
of a dumping ground at the end of time
for pruned stuff
and it's preyed upon by the monstrous
goliath now rinse layer was
as clueless we think about who's really
running the tva
uh and then sylvia just to get out of
this mess prunes herself so that she can
get in the void so hopefully get to the
other side of that void which is her
goal
um meanwhile loki is escaping the
various infighting prune loki's
including a president loki whose hand
gets bitten off by loki gator
uh and then in this void there is just a
uh
bevy of references to marvel comics in
the mcu of things
and uh there's you know we talked about
some of the thanos copter we thought
would only get referenced in uh
end game where he twisted his sword
around and looked like a helicopter
blade but no there is an actual thanos
copter in reality this is the most
important confirmation in the mcu
ever the thanos copter has been
confirmed yeah
uh i found and am currently finding more
and more stuff so uh stay tuned for the
breakdown for all of that um
so but in this episode when sylvie moves
to the
void she's able to accidentally enchant
it and see that there actually is
something on the other side of it
uh and then she runs into mobius who's
still alive driving a skinny's pizza car
and then uh they they meet up with the
other
loki's uh our loki and they decide to
enchant eliath so we can get to this
fortress beyond him
and the classic loki pulls an amazing
move by distracting alive with the
illusion of asgard the music
is incredible in this moment gives up
his life laughing
on the way down and then uh the
enchantment works loki actually proves
that he has powers of enchantment as
well
and then it opens a gate to this
mysterious fortress
um and we have a lot of questions about
where this is but we know from trailer
footage that this
is the structure that is positioned at
the top of that rock ring that's kind of
floating in that nebulous space
that doesn't look like the quantum realm
from the other trailer shot it looks
like some space at the end of all time
honestly
but okay so we're going to talk about
what exactly eliath is in the comics
uh and who this monster is most likely
guarding
uh real quick though you've been
eyeballing our
loki latest obsession out of time shirt
for five weeks now um just wanting to
get one for yourself i'm sure
but now is the time we've already sold
out a few sizes and some of the colors
and there's a limited supply left to the
other so order now and you can
watch this finale in style um
oh buying the shirt gets you uh you know
a couple benefits
uh one you get to wear this awesome
shirt
two you get to support new rockstars
directly uh but three it also unlocks
the ability to write an additional
custom shout out that will appear at the
bottom of the screen
uh like what do we see down here jason
says you guys are great miss minutes is
the mastermind
oh wow those are some fighting words
jason don't be abusing my wife
of being the mastermind of anything all
right she's my wife
my wife where's my wife
uh we'll talk about that michelangelo
says shout out to my man loki gator
thank you for using the right term
instead of croaky he's not a crocodile
he is a gator
can we just put this to bed i don't want
this to be the thing how people just you
know i
say gif instead of jif and then the
original thing gets lost it's not just a
pronunciation thing it's a different
species
anyway uh and he says hope we meet hell
gator
thor gator and hulk hater and star-lord
uh oh that would i want to see all the
avengers as gators oh my god yes we just
need like a whole animal universe just
like make that the spider-ham universe
honestly yeah
i didn't know that was something we
needed but now i do uh
and then uh david says eric voss was
right about the tva being variants
uh themselves pay attention mr molina
sarah cogel is the best
uh sarah it's great and you are also
great david yes yes
uh you know what every year i have to do
a what we got wrong
episode of big question where i just
like face the music for all my crazy
theories that were wrong throughout the
year
but like now we have found years later
that theories that i you know talked
about on the channel
are not in that insane and i don't want
to apologize anymore because who knows
four years from now what mcu writers
might try to rhett cannon
or retcon or reintroduce or decide was
actually true so no
no theories all theories are right
always you don't got to apologize
we marvel scientists bro we just make
theories based on the information we got
you that's right
think of the best arguments that we can
based on evidence based on exactly
yeah um so yeah just get yourself a
latest obsession shirt today before it's
gone at new rockstarsmerch.com but uh mt
let's dive into this opening question
so the first question of the day is wait
a damn minute what is eliath and who
or what is he guarding okay so empty
you're aware of this but we're just
gonna
catch up all viewers that might not be
aware elias is an entity from the marvel
comics
is described as a trans-temporal monster
uh it can kind of transcend different
eras of time uh
and it's one of these just abstract
beings it was first introduced in the
avengers the terminator subjective this
was early 90s
93 i believe and uh actually it's look
in the show is super accurate to the
comics it's a carnivorous
purple cloud and they nailed it which is
rare for the first time in comic book
movie history that we're happy to see
a carnivorous purple cloud i'm looking
at you fantastic four
rise with a silver surfer agreed agreed
so why is eliath important well eliath
rules over a time
empire that borders the kingdom of
kang the king so here's the thing folks
this isn't us forcing us
at this point uh goliath is most
directly associated with kang
eliath is kind of the rival to kang he's
the reason kang limits his time empire
to no earlier than 2000 bc
and uh in that comic arc it actually
begins with kang
uh dying and ravona rinslayer
accidentally releases eliath
and then ravono you know revives kang
who gives the avengers a weapon to use
against goliath which is actually
another entity named tempus
who is a character from earlier
fantastic four comics and then tempest
grows to match life and the two are just
kind of locked in eternal combat that
distracts them so that kang can
ha ha expand his empire now it is
possible that the one alive could be
guardian
could be tempest but tempest is you know
most commonly known as an agent
of kang slash immortus as he's known uh
when he's first introduced and uh kang
is confirmed to be a big bad coming in
the mcu there's all these other kang
clues
we've talked about the fact that like
this reality has the egyptian pyramids
and the sphinx like kang has
in chronopolis ravone of renssler being
in the show and she is kang's romantic
interest
so uh it's just a lot of things now are
pointing this direction but
most clearly in this episode the opening
shot on avengers tower
it does not say stark it does not say
it's not
even avengers a it is the letters
q-u-n-g
king which is a reference to king
enterprises
the company of nathaniel richards who
went by a different name but it is
nathaniel richards
who becomes kang the conqueror so now
you could
say that this tower is just a pruned
alternate reality detail like all
these other things are you know the
thereos copter throg and there's no
immediate implications on the future
with this
sure but these coincidences are just
getting really
hard to ignore for sure like it's just
like we got we got a live now
we got like we've we've had a rent
slayer and like we just all these pieces
are coming together yeah for like you
know
but that specific comic series i believe
it was a avengers
forever where like yeah that was another
yeah yeah so like all these pieces are
are elements of that story so like you
know when one of these creators create
this show
they look at the source material and
they take inspiration from like
different pieces so like
those pieces are not coincidences it's
probably just inspiration
that they're putting together for this
show so yes
probably coming most likely yeah in some
form right
now that castle that they're walking to
at the end is station atop of that
rock ring donut that we pointed out in
trailer breakdowns it has a glowing
lookout tower it's not in the quantum
realm
fish yeah oh a little bit right yeah i
was like is that why casey doesn't know
what a fish is because that rock kind of
looks like a fish i don't know
um like so this whatever that nebulous
space is we assume it is kind of at the
end of all time
it looks as though if you look closely
there could be a ship departing nearby
but it also looks like pieces of rock
debris that could be floating up or it's
classic loki pulling a classic loki
again
to hide himself yes that man did not die
at the end of that
like episode i'm very confident um
so my theory and i'm sure what many of
you are thinking is that this could be
the residence of kang
prime at the end of time who is just
there on his throne
feeding off the coronal energy of the
many histories that kang variants have
altered
and that it was he who created the tva
he who was pulling the strings
the man behind the curtain as a kind of
way to legitimize his dominion
and prune out all unwanted distractions
of things that could most
uh benefit him at the end of all time
now here's the thing if this show isn't
going in the direction of kang they're
just doing every possible thing to lay
the groundwork for him
way more than one division ever did for
mephisto let's be honest yeah i'm sure
like yeah for sure like they are laying
all this groundwork and like
i i feel like the biggest thing that
points to kang the conqueror being
the main factor of this show is the is
the name king the conqueror
like if he's coming to the mcu as kang
the conqueror
he's already have had to have conquered
something in the past like
the name implies that conquering has
already happened so like this is
probably setting up the the concept of
this is kang this is what he conquered
he conquered all the
the timelines of the multiverse now uh
uh that's a great point empty
now as mcu scientists as you said we
have to be willing to concede
that these might just be the biggest
nods we get decaying on this show
and that's it that maybe the person in
the castle could be some other variant
loki
or some older variant rent slayer maybe
some corporeal form of miss
minutes uh and then we get some
post-credits scene that more directly
references kang
uh or we get no kang at all and it's
really just dr doom
um but dr doom is probably coming to the
mcu at some point but it hasn't been
announced yet
and if we do see him it probably
wouldn't be for several years unlike
kang
he's going to be an ant-man that was
quantomania and probably show up in a
trailer within the next 12 months for
that
i would assume oh yeah for sure yeah so
i think we just have to keep in mind
that all of us
if you're watching this show if you're
me or you're empty or you're someone
commenting or you're just someone who
goes online looking into loki theories
you are in a pretty thick nerd bubble
and
we are probably not the majority of
people who are watching this show
whatever finale reveal we think would be
too predictable
will probably be mind-blowing to most of
the people who are watching this show
yes whether it is kang the conqueror who
we think might be a foregone conclusion
or too predictable or a loki variant
which we think would be too lame
no matter what this is it's gonna be
mind-blowing and so
based on that i'm gonna be okay with
whatever they do i'm not gonna say if
it's not gang all right
you know but all i know is that you know
none of us had any idea this season was
gonna be sitting on
eliath right i don't think elias showed
up in anyone's theories anyone's trailer
breaks down
no they waited to reveal this until the
penultimate episode
so if they can sit on a lion they can
hide literally any man behind the
curtain
in that castle up to and including kang
yes
i 100 believe that and like i believe
that like jonathan mages was asking like
on the street or something
if he was in loki and he was like i
don't know what you're talking about oh
i don't know i i don't know what that is
so like marvel what's marvel who are you
what day is it i only read the comics
off of the newspaper
um only garfield but no i i think that
you know with him being so coy yeah like
you said
i think it's really possible that you
know marvel's just hiding because
they had sif from us completely like we
had no idea if was in this episode
i mean in the previous episode so like
yeah marvel will be hiding stuff so
yeah you never know um and i think like
it'd be one thing if it was one division
where like after episode seven
it's clear that the show was showing its
cards right they were saying
it's not like they're gonna reveal one
villain and then oh another villain
here they're saying trust us you do not
know the villain of the series yet
that will be revealed in the final
episode so like if they're gonna
wait and like reveal something big why
would you just reveal
another variant loki i think that's my
issue with like the big bad as a variant
loki just because we've seen loki as a
villain
in the mcu before and this show's whole
mission statement is to show different
shades of loki so to just go back to the
first version of them that we've seen
i don't know if that would be that
satisfying to general audiences
like i think those of us in the nerd
bubble are like out thinking ourselves
trying to like be like no it's this this
we're like in that conspiracy theory
episode of community where it's like
wait no it has to be this we're double
crossing it's a double fake
uh no i just think general audiences
they would just see like tom
hiddleston's face again
they'd be like oh so how is that
different from
all the other past episodes where they
did a variant loki
yeah no for sure i think that this this
big bad threat is either going to be
like kang or some other multiversal
threat because we have that multiversal
factor that is goliath in um the void or
it's basically limbo but it's the void
and so like if if if this
entity can control such a powerful
multiversal threat like a life
then he's probably also a multiversal or
or time based entity like king
right yeah i don't think it's going to
be a loki as a
secret puppet and this is i mean and
some people say there's no way marvel's
going to introduce
a big bad or like a huge major character
for the movies in a disney plus series
i can't say too much i'll just say
wait for black widow because empty and i
have seen black widow
just wait for black widow and then we'll
talk two days from now okay we'll talk
two days from now
wait a minute and then also like we know
at the end of the first avengers film
they had a post-credits scene with
thanos marvel
loves to have a big bad character that
all these other stories gonna gravitate
around like someone in the shadows and
it's clear
kang is probably gonna be that for the
mcu oh yes for sure like kang they're
setting up kang for some big
things um in in this show i feel and in
ant-man the wasp like there's just
they're slaying that groundwork so
yeah that's what marvel does um so we
have some more questions we want to talk
about
from this episode first we want to thank
some people who helped us make it
starting with credit karma money so we
all like instant gratification with
credit karma money you could win cash
reimbursements for debit purchases
credit card money is a brand new
checking account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
up to five thousand dollars just pay
with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added back to
your spend account credit karma money
has already given away over 3 million
dollars in instant karma to over 50
000 credit karma members open your fdic
insured spend account for free there's
no minimum balance requirements no
overdraft fees and free withdrawals from
a network of over 50 000 atms right now
visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign it for free and start
winning an instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions in terms of ply see rules
banking services provided by mvb bank
inc member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
apply we also want to thank keeps for
sponsoring this episode more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness and there are only two
fda approved medications that prevent
hair loss well good news
keeps offers both of them keeps has a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
i personally hate going to doctor's
appointments it's never at a convenient
time you have to park you got to sit in
a waiting room it's about as much fun as
losing your hair
is i assume well keeps offers convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door
every three months so you don't have to
leave your home to go to the doctor the
pharmacy for this
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
to keep costs low
their proven results arrive on your
doorstep in a discreet package
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors with hair loss
prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com marvel to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash marvel to get your first
month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash marvel and we wanna thank
blue chew for sponsoring this episode so
our friends at blue two have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in a chewable format at a fraction
of the cost
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package
if you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength
and a blue chew it's chewable so you
you know it says in the name it's blue
it's blue and chewy if you chew it
chew it you don't just swallow it so if
you hate swallowing pills you don't have
to worry about that so if you could
benefit from some extra confidence when
it's time to perform visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code inside
marvel at checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring the show
all right so uh back to our discussion
mt wait a damn minute
what do you think was the history behind
the pruned easter eggs that we saw
throughout the episode like the thanos
copter
throg the sphinx all the other stuff
where do these things come from
do you think um they have to come from
alternate
timelines alternate realities that the
tva has pruned throughout
however long they've been alive and so
like these various
objects were probably from various nexus
events that
um you know the i'm assuming thanos was
like you know flagging the thanos copter
was like no you should have
banged left instead of making right
you're going to jail
um and throg i don't know what throg did
to get there but like you know all these
people in the sphinx
i think the sphinx is very interesting
but i believe that there's a connection
between uh
kang and the sphinx in in the comics um
and you know with his identity as a
mortis if i'm not mistaken
immortalist and then he was uh pharaoh
rama tut at
that time of the egyptian days yeah
that's exactly what i was thinking rama
tut exactly it's
with the pharaoh rama tut so like maybe
this is you know
somehow how kang got involved if there
was like a
original tva and kane got sent to limbo
and then he figured out i'd like the
secret behind the line but yeah this is
very much
like um the concept of limbo in the
comics where like
all i believe mobius says this one know
who says this
is one of the low-keys um where like all
of like basically time is basically in
one moment
it's very much like limbo but yeah what
do you think what do you think are the
the history behind these easter eggs i
mean i love seeing these because i think
it reminds us that
for any doubters marvel studios has not
forgotten the comics
and the things we most love the wackiest
stuff we most love from the comics
because i think after you watch shows
like wanda vision and the falcon the
winter soldier you worry that
you know these tv writers and directors
might just be taking um kind of thematic
inspiration from who the character
is uh and then kind of building its own
world around them that only loosely
references the comics maybe thinks the
comics are lame or think we're lame for
reading them
um this show embraces these elements
from the comics and when it adapts
things from the comics it makes them
look as accurate to the comics as we can
that the endoscopter isn't like a cool
version
of the thanos copter it says thanos on
it it's yellow it is 100
a real-life version of the thanos copper
which is amazing
well done so wonderful uh eliath looks
like goliath in the comics
um uh thrawn loki his whole classic loki
yeah exactly so they're just doing this
to be cute i think they're
acknowledging the existence of a
multiverse that will look like the
comics multiverse
and that is so exciting whether they do
that by the end of the show
or you know wait to do it to multiverse
of madness or introduce it in spider-man
no way home
the fact that they're aware of it and
they're willing to go there and the fact
that of the three
disney plus marvel shows we've seen so
far this is the one that is having a
second season
shows us that this is the tone marvel
wants to stick with going forward
this isn't like a standalone mini series
it's just getting a character from a to
b
this is active world building that we're
seeing in the mcu
so i think the implication is what you
said mt i think these are coming from
alternate timelines some of which we'll
visit most of which we probably won't
uh but the idea is that we can now
yeah anything is possible like it would
have been great to see like an x-men
like fox universe oh that would have
been wild
dude if they had i mean what would it be
just like their version of the
the x-mansion or their blackbird jet or
uh
or like maybe like the um what do you
call it like xavier's machine why am i
blanking on this
i mean xavier's wheelchair right that's
kind of yeah the wheelchair that would
have been
just a wheelchair sticking out of the
rubble man we would have gone straight
back to evan peters if that had happened
kind of burned heavy just confirmed this
quicksilver yeah no it's something like
that like either like a like a
wheelchair or like maybe like
cyclops is like visor like something
cool like a nice little thing
but speaking of um this void and like
this this uh all these easter eggs
this kind of reminds me and this sort of
feels like a hint towards
secret wars because of the battle world
of the 2015
secret wars series and i'm just like oh
look at all these elements they're
meshing them all into one
area so like maybe this is kevin feige
getting us primed
for like a battle world situation and if
it is 2015 secret wars that
would make us think uh that would make
us think doom
right because doom was the the person
who assembled battle world in that arc
and i you know there were elements from
that first episode of loki where it's
like
you see the incursions it looks like the
incursion sparks between the timelines
and there was a multiversal war that is
kind of what 2015 secret wars was
um and we have a feeling they're going
in that direction i just feel like we
have like two or three steps of movie
and tv show releases we need to have
before we get there
but like it's the closest looking at
this void is the closest i think we've
seen to a version of battle world in the
mcu even though i don't think this
in particular is battle world oh yeah
this this is not battle world at all
this is just like its own thing but like
this is just like the closest
it's given us it's given us the terms
for it you know it's given us a
dictionary of a glossary of references
so that when they eventually introduce
these things it's like oh yeah that's
like yeah that's old news we saw that in
loki years ago
yeah it's like literally building the
the laws of the universe
yes world universe building exactly
we're getting accustomed to all this
weird which is i
i like it like i like the how the
concept of the multiverse has entered
the public lexicon it's so cool
anyway yeah everyone's on board with
this now i love it um
maybe a simple question a simple no here
mt but
i think we should talk about it wait a
day a minute is rinse layer lying
about not knowing the time keepers were
fake i
don't think so she was very sketchy at
the at the beginning of the episode and
i was like i don't trust anything that
you're saying but she's right
humanly um like curious but what do you
think um i
i think the fact that i couldn't trust
anything she told sylvie right
because obviously all of that was uh
manipulative information
um and just yeah i was stalling and it
made me question miss minutes more
than rent slayer honestly but uh the
fact that
come on i know i'm sorry we'll get to
her we'll get to her
uh but like when uh rensselaer talked to
b15
to me and then like b15 was kinda able
to say like you don't know what happened
was able to use her uh prosecutorial
skills to kind of get the truth out
to me that was like oh rensselaer might
really not know what's going on
i wish we had a good reaction shot of
her back in the timekeeper's chamber
lapsed episode
when the central one guys be headed um
like even she's just like huh
robot um because yeah i i think there is
more to rensselaer's story obviously
we're gonna
hopefully find out what the whole thing
with the pen and of
uh franklin d roosevelt high school was
about i
again i think ren slayer's mystery kind
of lurks around this possibility of kang
right mm-hmm because again why bring in
rent slayer if not bringing kang
oh yeah for sure like that there's going
to be that kane connection because all
those factors are there that we said
before and it would be very strange
especially with the show dealing with
time very very strongly
that kang wouldn't be involved so yeah
her and kang have definitely have to
have some
history for lack of i mean but no pun
intended
let's uh talk about uh loki gator wait a
damn minute what do you think is loki
gator's backstory he was the one of the
uh like they had that one joke where he
ate the wrong neighbor's cat right
he was supposed to eat one neighbor's
cat he ate the wrong neighbors
so that implies there is it's not just
the fact that he is an alligator it's
the fact that like
he's strayed from the alligator timeline
and there is a sacred timeline version
of loki gator
or some universe where loki gator exists
like do we think there is a future for
this character in the mcu
and i hope so yeah i think that whatever
fan favorite character like that people
really latch onto
like that character will survive into
future reincarnations
so like you know loki gator is one of
those characters like people love loki
gator i don't think he's gonna go away
he's probably gonna be implemented into
the comics honestly because people love
him so much
yeah but uh in terms of loki gator's
history um that cat comments really
interesting because like that makes me
think that
what if you know odin and thor found
the loki gator as the loki gator on like
um what's it called
uh yotenheim or something they're like
hey this is pretty cool like we just
killed
all these frost giants let's take this
alligator as a trophy
until they brought him into asgard and
he eats like an asgardian cat it's like
you know
and that's our is an asgardian cat a uh
um a rabbit right because don't they
think all mammals are different than
what we think they are
or is it a fluorescence he eats a like
an actual rabbit or a flirkin
yeah well i mean who would win in a
fight between a flurk and look at gator
probably the flurkin right i gotta
probably the flurkin but loki gator he
got some moves as we see in this episode
oh yeah
he took yeah he's vicious yeah
all right a couple more questions but
thanks to better help for sponsoring
this episode we've all experienced times
where something was interfering with our
happiness or preventing us from
achieving our goals well better help is
here to help they assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
who you can start communicating with in
under 48 hours now this is not a crisis
line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online
they have a broad range of expertise
available for clients worldwide
so log into your account anytime and
schedule weekly video or
phone sessions it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today so check the reviews
section of their website for
testimonials from folks who have gotten
something from their service
visit betterhelp.com marvel that's
betterhelp
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
and here's a special offer for our
inside marvel audience get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
marvel all right mt i'm sorry to talk
about your girl like this but wait a
damn minute
what is miss minutes hiding there's
something i don't know i don't know
she's a big bad i'm just saying
she knows something do you think she's
hiding something from me
i don't she might you gotta call
cheaters
talk to your clock just talk to your
clock empty
damn she's she's hiding i i knew there's
something weird that i knew there was
something wrong when she didn't have any
hands
on her face she's hiding those hands
behind her back
some sketchy um
no um this man is a secret she's she was
very very sketchy in this episode
um she was just like hey you know just
looking for those files for
for rabona even though her and ravona
didn't really have like the
hey can you just fake this for me like
this was like i'm just gonna
alert the police anyway um so
yeah so she's sort of hiding something i
don't really know
because she does seem in some degrees
that she
is you know kind of innocent in a way
because her reactions are kind of
like oh gosh like what's going on like
oh like i don't really know
so like part of me because i love this
minute is like you know maybe she's just
good maybe she's just
a nice little innocent little ai that
just doesn't really know what's going on
but what do you think what do you think
mrs secret is i mean yeah she does seem
innocent i
i don't think she is evil um i don't
know if she has a capacity for evil but
i think she is more than just like
uh automated response system i think um
whoever the big bad at this show is
gonna be i think miss minutes is gonna
be revealed to be some kind of tragic
variant or some soul of something that
he trapped
and forces him to like run the
day-to-day or the tva or to be the tva's
clerk or something like that
i think we're gonna like tear up when we
learn the true story of miss minutes
whatever it is and then we're gonna feel
really bad for her the fact that like
whether it's kang or doom or some
version of he who remains or something
else i think
the fact like we're going to see her
form or her history
i hope tara strong gets to play whatever
that part is oh my gosh
she's just like in addition to being a
great voice actress she's also just a
good actress you know
yes phenomenal i'm like imagine if miss
minutes is like a variant of friday
uh the ai because like friday is a day
technically it's named birthday which is
a unit of time so it's like hey
who knows maybe but like that's just the
way i just had a theory mt
friday you know friday is based on and
you know the days of the week are named
after gods
friday is frigga's day yeah that's a
really great connection miss minutes
an alternate reality friga who is
trapped
it turned into a day and then converted
to miss minutes i might have lost it i
think i lost it i'm sorry
i think so confirmed
yeah confirmed well as we look ahead to
this finale mt
there's lots of stuff that's gonna go on
we know from trailer footage that
they're gonna go into this castle
we know it's kind of floating on this
rock orb ring whatever that is
uh there's gonna be some fight that
happens and it's someone will be
revealed
but we know this show is gonna live on
for a second season
so how do we think this series is gonna
live on for a second season
who is gonna survive uh who will come
back
um do we want mobius to come back and
live on at some point will the tva
still exist in some form or will loki
face some other kind of
um you know trans-dimensional threat or
something that tries to rein him in
i think that if they're setting up this
just me being
wild but like you know i just don't
trust classic loki because that final
like you know scene was very powerful
and was very very cool and it would
have would have been a very cool
redemptive thing for this loki who who
wants to
who who seemingly as he said wanted to
be different but at the end of the day
you cannot
trust a loki loki's are deceivers and
this man is literally dressed like the
most mischievous like classic form of
loki and we all know that loki loves to
fake his own death that's a staple of
loki in a thor film it's like you know
what i'm here that i'm gonna fake my
death
so i think that you know he faked his
own death here because he's pro
he's like one of the most powerful
illusionists that we've ever seen in the
mcu like that freaking that was insane
but he's also one of the oldest loki's
that we've seen it was implied i mean
or he's not as guardian but these guys
live like five thousand years right so
that's
like he could have been around just
perfecting his illusion casting
exactly so like i feel like this man he
heard that
you know eliath was the key to this the
the the what
the timekeepers and all this power so
he's just biting his time he's like you
know what
i'm gonna go through this door i'ma see
what's good and so by the end of this
series
he's gonna try to he's gonna do
something some type of power play
that's gonna like launch season two of
loki and it's probably gonna be some
multiverse
craziness because you know i feel like
this show is going to
um as far as i i can tell from like
interviews with michael waldron and all
that stuff
that this show is going to launch into a
lot of it was going to push a lot of the
multiverse of madness problems or cause
a lot of the problems in multiple
madness so um yeah i think that like
classic loki is probably the key to
season two here but
what do you think it's it's hard right
because normally when you think of a
second season the show there are certain
rules of the world
some kind of patterns that get set and
for a while i thought the pattern was
going to be this can be a bit of a
procedural like a goofy doctor who
style procedural where there is always
some home base that he goes back to and
that's the tva
and there's some other time adventure
and here there's some crisis here or
they're hunting a new
time serial killer or something like
that but here now like the very
foundations of the show get rattled
every episode
so you never really know what the actual
home base or setting of the show will be
so it's hard to conceive like well then
it's not necessarily a procedural it's
like
what other kind of broader crisis will
loki try to
climb the chaos ladder of in the next
season
and i think it would maybe be in the
aftermath of multiverse of madness what
uh what i kind of hope is that like loki
now gets to explore
other things that we have not associated
with the main
mcu that maybe after multiverse of
madness we're okay
visiting x-men uh universes or fantastic
four
universes uh and then that loki gets to
like dance in those worlds a little bit
and look loki can be used to just like
start to establish these other
previously non-canonical things as just
like
it's just another reality and we'll
visit it soon bro
i would love for that to happen first of
all but like for
for a season two of loki this is again
me being wild to include
deadpool and cable right yeah they did
their whole time travel
thing or whatever the hell they're doing
so like it'd be cool to like just
incorporate that like
that's a really good idea i like that
yeah um well we have one more episode i
can't wait to watch it with umt
uh it's gonna be exciting but that is it
for this episode of inside marvel again
my breakdown of episode five will be on
the channel tomorrow keep an eye out for
that
uh and don't forget to uh check out our
many great loki merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow mt
at mastertainment follow me at eavos
follow new rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching
and we will close with our favorite
moment of the episode
[Music]
you